timo nico willkommen zu einem neuen
video ich das heutige mit luft wirbelt
und wir erwarten heute youtuber am
echten namen leute dafür die liebe alle
ausgeholfen ferne
diese auch in der beschreibung verlinkt
die hat uns die youtuber vorbereitet da
habe ich halt auch was für was das geht
wieder zurück am ort der wm ihren basar
wer zuerst die antwort weiß wenn der
echte name gesagt wird und der gewinner
und verlierer
für einzelne war wieder lassen sich
david wenn sie das gleichnamige
bestrafen
bei mir waren
der verlierer muss 100 millionen euro
bekommen
[Musik]
die kein geld
wir machen ja auf welche marken mann ich
weiß nicht wer 100 prozent richtig
bekannter 100
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gerade in sachen tv das verbot war der
wechsel sei aber ich hätte jetzt so
[Gelächter]
verwaschen 2533 kopf an kopf rennen
ja ja bekannt wird ein deutscher auf
jeden fall waren die namen sagen wir
alle weiß wer ist nicht nochmal ist sein
vorname in dem kanal namen halt so
vorhanden gar nicht
da hab ich überhaupt kein plan das leder
ein das ist nicht wahr ich dachte auch
simon wie kommt man darauf sein dessen
filme man ja vor heißt vor allem jeder
seiner freundin einfach keinen sinn wenn
sie ihn sehen kleiner doch joshua in den
videos jetzt als als
glaube ich auf jeden fall laufen oder
wie man eine 5 zu 3 will nächste woche
geht's nicht
oder warst du kannst du dich um alles
gewusst aber ich habe zuerst aber du
hast die kommentare
gewonnen hat der beschreibung natürlich
auch die andere ist die vorbereitung
kann sich alle noch mal schickt die
abonnierte flaig und bis zum nächsten
video verlierst du das flugzeug aus